and what was it like when this came
through I was holding my dog I was
sitting on the stool holding my dog this
was a game plan all through the years
you know to go in that little bathroom
and the electric never went off because
the electric went off in the bathroom at
the same time I felt the stool come up
out of the floor and I rolled around a
little bit and when it stopped I was
right there that presto cooker is what I
saw you were lying there in the Hubble
and I never lost consciousness and I
hollered for my little dog and he didn't
answer it didn't come so I know he's in
here somewhere but it just I mean it was
there and it was gone just just no time
and then it was light and I thought well
I'm okay and I had some stuff on top of
me and I started wiggling it are you
able to comprehend yet what happened
here I know exactly what happened here
exactly and what do you anyway
what do you think of all this this is
your neighborhood I can't imagine this
is life in the big city the dog dog dog
well I thought God just answered one
prayer to let me be okay
the edge of both of them because this
was my line my stick
Oh